Kristen goes like this hey
guess what there is I said huh she says
I'll play place I say really she says
yup
I said oh she says let's go bring cow I
said I got to do a podcast this was a
few days ago she says meet us there I go
like this bet
okay give me yes there I go I go like
this facts
um
I am doing my podcast in the middle of
my podcast she texts me a video of her
and Calvin
playing at the indoor playground I go
like this
oh dude
it could be Armageddon
I'll get there
that's how
life affirming it looked
I go like this oh that's a place oh I
would never go to that place oh Calvin's
there
oh it could be Armageddon
I'll get there right that's what having
a son is you don't know how
this is what having a son is for your
life you're living like this obviously
you have a son boom okay you go like
this you go I would never do this [__] I
would never do that [__] I would never
do this I would never do that I would
never do the other thing oh you have a
son let's do all those things that's
what it is
so now Candyland indoor playground
on the top of my list of my sons there
so I go oh I can't wait to finish this
podcast and get over to Candyland indoor
playground quickly I hit up David
Sullivan yo meet us at Candyland indoor
player he goes like this man I can't sit
still and be by myself because of I I
need to run from life right he was doing
nothing so guess what would I be there
bet because his problem is he can't sit
still and do nothing
so I go hey you don't want to be alone
in your thoughts guess what me neither
let's meet again
so he is hey man all right I'll meet you
there I do I get the kitten Lane indoor
playground
Calvin doesn't know I arrived yet I see
him playing in the ball pit
and I
my heart dude goes like
it's like the end of the Grinch okay
I am growing
and I say I can't wait to see him and I
say Gavin what's up dude my son
is
flipping out
the whole time he's just ah
do you see the spikeable
those costumes over
this is a workbench
he's doing like that and I'm I go like
this can you get in can you get in the
it's like a whole tunnel where you go in
the thing and over the you know it's
like a a bubble gum Vietnam you know
and you and I'm
I'm
I as I'm saying can adults get in I'm
I'm in already like can adults get shoes
are off I'm in I don't even notice oh
okay by the time I already threw half
the tunnel I I've noticed other adults
are in there too okay good because I was
gonna be getting in no matter what
you're not going to take this moment
away from me from my son I want to be a
totally invested and involved here so he
goes so he's like Dad come here let's
look let's go to the spikeable I go to
the spiky ball shows me the spiky ball
he says look how do we get over there to
the boss how do we get to the boxes how
do we get to this the ice cream let's go
and what I'm doing the whole [__]
thing dude it is absolutely
gorgeous it is so gorgeous to be in this
bubblegum Vietnam
and by the way it's really hard David
Sullivan couldn't do it a little bit
Jazz he's not flexible you know your boy
he's a bit like Gumby I found like I'm
very very flexible
so I'm doing this [__] and um
and Calvin is in the ball pit trying to
hide in the ball pit come in the ball
pit I jump in the ball pit there's
another kid in the ball pit now let's
just say he's
I don't want to say he's he will be a
jerk when he grows up how about that
that's what I'll say about him uh he's
gonna be a jerk when he grows up
you know why here's how I know that
because I was watching my son
and the kid looks at me and runs up to
me and goes like this
say my face is the microphone he goes
like this ah
and I go oh
I go okay buddy
walks back comes back forward and goes
ah to my face and I'm like okay man like
he's five and I'm like this is not I
don't know you dude
more importantly you don't know me also
don't breathe in my face right kid right
but I'm 42 so I don't make him I don't
feel it make him feel bad for any of
this I don't shame him but
hey hey get the
if I saw Calvin walking up to somebody
doing that I'm gonna have so many words
with Calvin all right
the fact that these kids aren't these uh
adults aren't like taking care of the
kids and doing the thing and I know
parenting is hard I get it sometimes I
spend like [__] hours and days and
days with Calvin and I'm like all right
bro best believe Calvin never does
something to someone else I'm gonna be
checking them right nobody checks their
kid it's unbelievable that's how much
you realize as a family as a parent
because you get to see that's what your
relatives apparently you get to see
other parents do the [__]
so
I go in a ball pit the kid the kid who
growled at me
[__] takes a ball from the pit looks
at David Sullivan goes like this
Rockets the ball up into David
Sullivan's eye David goes oh like that
like a [__] right and and he goes oh he
really got me in a good he really got me
and I'm I'm I would be laughing but I'm
I'm already I already had the anger and
the hatred towards the kid because the
kid goes to me twice once I let you get
the kid picks up another ball tosses it
families their families right there
doesn't do [__]
so I say hey buddy hey you're all right
you know
nothing
kid does it again kid does it a fourth
time then the family says well I don't
say the kid's name is Steve she says
Stephen
do not do that do not do that you do not
do that so I'm like all right good says
nothing to David Sullivan and I'm like
oh so it's all about discipline in your
kid and not apologizing for what the
[__] happened so now
we get it right
it's a little bit self-centered
so then Calvin takes a ball and starts
throwing it not not hurting but like
like tossing it onto the kid he's laying
down and I'm like I see what Calvin's
doing he's kind of doing a little bit of
Retribution and I was a little bit proud
of him but I said to Calvin I said hey
hey buddy don't put the ball on the
other but you you don't know that kid
and don't don't do that as much as I
wanted him to because he grounded me in
through the [__] thing right David's
eye and so the so then
we're leaving the place
and I tell you that story because I want
to tell you something about something
later but we're leaving the place and
Calvin
I look over
and there's a little girl like uh
she can't talk yet like she's one year
and a few months you know maybe 14
months and she's just crying
and the moms like buckling up the kids
uh overalls or whatever it is
and Calvin looks at the crying little
girl and I mean I'm Calvin's dad so I
see there's like anguish on Calvin's
face looking at this little girl and
he's just looking at her and I'm right
looking at Calvin but Calvin's looking
at the girl and I I just feel this oh no
that little girl's crying coming from
his dumb I know the little girl's crying
because she's just like crying she's a
little girl but Calvin sees this pain on
this little girl's face
or whatever it is and Calvin says to me
quietly
I think I need to hold that little
girl's hand
and I said oh yeah
and it was like I said nothing Calvin
already started walking over to the
little girl and just holds her hand and
looks at her
while she's crying and the little girl's
crying just holding Calvin's hand and
Calvin is there
comforting this [__] out of that 13
month old
and I'm like that's beautiful and I
don't mean to compare but what the [__]
did your kid do today
congratulations
[Music]